♪ ♪
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS GETTING
VERY NERVOUS OVER NEXT WEEK'S
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR'S RACE A NEW
POLLING SPELLING DISASTER FOR
TERRY McAULIFFE.
THE REPUBLICAN GLENN YOUNGKIN
SURGING AHEAD OF McAULIFFE.
McAULIFFE NOT LEFT WITH A LOT
OF OPTIONS TO TURN THINGS
AROUND.
THE DEEPLY UNPOPULAR
KAMALA HARRIS IS SET TO CAMPAIGN
WITH HIM TODAY.
SHE CONTINUES TO CLAIM THE
OUTRAGE OVER EDUCATION IN THIS
STATE IS FAKE NEWS.
>> HOW ARE YOU GOING TO WORK
WITH THOSE PARENTS WHO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THINGS ARE
BEING TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS?
>> LET'S BE VERY CLEAR.
THIS IS ALL GENERATED BY GLENN
YOUNGKIN.
TRYING TO DEFINE THE TACTIC.
IT'S A RACIST DOG WHISTLE.
I HATE IT.
IT IS PITTING PARENTS AGAINST
PARENTS AND PARENTS AGAINST
TEACHERS.
>> Jesse: SPEAKING OF RACIST
DOG WHISTLE.
WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY PUT A BUNCH OF WHAT WHITE
GUYS TIKI TORCHES?
>> Katie: THE DIVERSITY BOX.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A WOMAN,
PERSON OF COLOR.
THEY ALLOWED --
AT THE EVENT IN CHARLOTTESVILLE
FOUR DEMOCRATS TIED TO THE
VIRGINIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY SHOWED
UP IN THE SAME KHAKI PANTS, TIKI
TORCHES WITH THE TAGS STILL ON
THEM, THE SAME WHITE SHIRTS AND
RANDOM HATS.
THE MEDIA PICKED UP ON IT AND
SAID LOOK AT THESE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS WHO SHOWED UP TO
BACK GLENN YOUNGKIN.
TWITTER DID IT'S THING AND
CONSERVATIVE REPORTERS CAUGHT ON
IT.
THEY ARE TWITTER PROFILES.
MAYBE SOME OF THEM WORK FOR THEM
A CAMPAIGN.
THEY DENY IT.
>> Jesse: NOT THE MOST HONEST
CAMPAIGN.
>> Katie: I'M SURE THEY'LL BE
CALLING THE FBI TO TRACK DOWN
THESE WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
THEY BLEW IT.
>> Greg: RUNNING AROUND.
>> Jesse: THIS DOES NOT SOUND
LIKE A COMPETENT CAMPAIGN.
>> Greg: BIDEN SHOWING UP DID
NOT HELP.
LIKE A GUEST WHO SHOWS UP AND
THROWS UP AT THE BUFFET.
WE ARE SEEING IS AN AMAZING
PHENOMENON.
PARENTS ARE WOKE IN A GOOD
SENSE, THEY ARE WOKEN UP.
THEY HAD NO IDEA FOR THE LONGEST
TIME HOW MUCH CONTEMPT FOR
TEACHERS UNIONS TEACHERS IN THE
WHOLE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM HAS FOR
THEM.
THEIR INTENT IS TO BRAINWASH THE
KIDS.
THIS IS THE POSITIVE ASPECT OF
KOBE.
THAT'S WHERE THE PARENTS LEARNED
ALL OF THIS, AT HOME.
THEY SAW HOW LEFT-WING VERY
TEACHERS WERE, THEY HATE THE
KIDS AND THEY HATE THEM.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT VIRGINIA.
IT'S A EDUCATION PROBLEM
WRIT LARGE.
IT'S TIME TO WRESTLE CONTROL
FROM THIS MONSTROUS MONOLITH.
EVERYONE SAW IT AT HOME.
>> Jesse: ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," EDUCATION
IS THE TOP ISSUE IN THE RACE.
>> Shannon: WE'VE SEEN THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS, SUBURBS
OF D.C.
IT MAKES YOU THINK THAT THE DOJ
MEMO THAT CAME OUT TALKING ABOUT
POTENTIAL THREATS, HASN'T BLOWN
UP ON DEMOCRATS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
PARENTS WERE ALREADY UPSET.
FEELING LIKE SOMEONE WAS COMING
AFTER THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
IT HAS BEEN A BACKLASH FOR
McAULIFFE EVER SINCE THEN.
PARENTS HAVE SAID NOT ONLY DO
YOU HAVE THESE THINGS THAT I
DISAGREE WITH THAT I AM SUPPOSED
TO SIT DOWN AND SHUT UP?
NUMBERS HAVE CONTINUED TO TAKE
DOWN FOR McAULIFFE.
>> Jesse: HE HAS A LOT OF
MOMENTUM, GLENN YOUNGKIN.
PREDICTIONS?
>> Jessica: I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE WITHIN THE MARGIN OF
ERROR.
STATISTICALLY TIED.
>> Greg: YOU ARE MAKING YOUNG
GREG ANGRY.
>> Jesse: IT WORKS.
>> Jessica: TWO OTHER POLLS.
YOUNGKIN UP 3.
McAULIFFE UP ONE TRAIN FOR THE
EDUCATION QUESTION IS
FASCINATING BECAUSE McAULIFFE
IS DOWN 15 POINTS WITH PARENTS
WHO HAVE KIDS AGES KINDERGARTEN
TO 12TH GRADE.
VIRGINIA IS NOT AS BLUE AS
NEW JERSEY.
PHIL MURPHY IS IN A TIGHTER RACE
THAN HE WOULD LIKE.
NEW JERSEY WILL STAY BLUE.
IF IT BECOMES A WAVE, THIS
EDUCATION VOTERS.
THE EXPECTATION IS THAT WE HAVE
JOBS IN THE ECONOMY.
THAT BECOMES THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE.
THERE IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE A
BIG REVERSAL IN TERMS OF
MESSAGING COMING OUT ABOUT IT.
REPUBLICANS, YOUNGKIN HAS BEEN
SMART.
HE CAMPAIGNS ALONE.
HE HAS FUND-RAISERS WITH
HIGH-PROFILE REPUBLICANS BUT
WHEN YOU GO TO A RALLY, YOU SEE
GLENN YOUNGKIN AND THE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY
ATTENTION.
WE HAVE NATIONALIZED IT BUT IF
IT DOESN'T WORK IN THIS
SCENARIO, THEN WE'VE GOT TO
THINK ABOUT THAT NEW MODEL FOR A
REPUBLICAN RACE.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE A LOT TO
DO.
LITTLE GRE